en este camión hay una carga muy valiosa
cilindros de oxígeno la oleada de
contagios en india ha hecho que
encontrar y llevar suministros a los
enfermos sea un reto fuera de la tienda
más de un centenar de personas han hecho
fila con la esperanza de que quede
suficiente para llenar sus botellas
román es para mi tío tiene 75 años de
una condición crítica el propietario de
la tienda ha recibido la entrega de su
proveedor habitual antes de la oleada de
kobe vendía el oxígeno líquido a
empresas de construcción pero será antes
tan verdad en este momento realmente no
hay suficiente sólo tengo suficiente
para la mitad de las solicitudes
los particulares están recurriendo a
buscar desesperadamente oxígeno líquido
por su cuenta en india los hospitales
están desbordados algunos reaccionan lo
que les queda bajando los niveles de los
respiradores el gobierno dice que puede
producir 7200 toneladas al día pero la
necesidad diaria con el coronavirus es
de 8 mil toneladas india tiene reservas
de 55 mil toneladas pero la distribución
sigue siendo un reto así pues el
transporte de oxígeno en este momento es
una pesadilla logística en india hay un
déficit de camiones cisterna crío geox
tenemos algunos de alemania así que
estamos tratando de cubrir este déficit
además también hay escasez de cisternas
para almacenar este oxígeno
desde hace una semana el gobierno ha
estado enviando camiones a diferentes
regiones del país a través de un
programa llamado estímulo exprés
ante el creciente enfado contra el
gobierno nueva delhi ha intentado
tranquilizar a la población diciendo que
los suministros médicos y la ayuda
internacional ha llegado y que hay más
en camino